Can a thought be infectious?
Is it possible that transferring an idea can
happen as easily as catching the common cold?
Someone gets it, then transmits it to another
person, who then passes it on to someone else
and so on?
Imagine, for a moment, that information is
a disease.
We can’t see information or feel it.
We can read it in books or on the Internet,
but actually seeing it or feeling it inside
our heads is impossible.
So, what if something could taint the information
we absorb?
Use it to slip its way undetected into your
mind, then pass from you to your friends,
your family, your co-workers?
How would you know it was there?
And how could you prevent it from getting
into your head?
Perhaps it is time you were introduced to
SCP-3002.
Over its many years of studying and containing
anomalous beings and entities, the SCP Foundation
has encountered a number of creatures with
memetic abilities.
If you are unfamiliar with the term, memetic
usually refers to data or information that
has been manipulated in order to influence
or subconsciously change a person’s behavior.
This can take any form, from text and images,
to spoken phrases and other audio.
For example, a form of memetic influence we
have all experienced at some point is product
placement.
If you’ve ever watched a character in a
movie or on TV using a certain product, then
that may have made you decide that you want
to buy that same product for yourself.
That idea was planted in your head by something
you saw, and had a subliminal influence on
your behavior.
SCP-3002 is one such entity that uses memetic
stimuli for its own nefarious purposes.
Some anomalies, like SCP-2440, use memetic
information to spread knowledge of themselves
among human beings, getting stronger the more
people learn about it.
SCP-3002, on the other hand, is information.
This entity is a thought, a living, sentient
thought, with a number of abilities that allow
it to influence the minds of human beings.
It is hard to picture a thought, let alone
one that is alive.
Since we can’t see information, the idea
of something so abstract having a tangible
form boggles the mind.
SCP-3002 is capable of shape shifting, and
while it does not possess its own consistent
shape, the entity is able to transform itself
into the form of any piece of information
it chooses.
Existing as pure information means that it
is intangible to any beings that possess physical
bodies.
But what makes SCP-3002 a threat to everyone
at the Foundation, and earned this entity
its Keter classification, is its power to
manipulate a person’s mind or memories,
allowing SCP-3002 to directly enter human
minds.
Moving at the speed that thoughts can travel
through the brain, the entity is almost impossible
to kill or kept contained.
SCP-3002 can spread like a sickness through
a human population, attacking new minds and
taking control of its victims.
According to the Foundation’s research,
there is only one way to remove the influence
of SCP-3002.
Anyone that comes under the control of this
entity has to undergo complex, intricate,
and risky brain surgery in order to physically
remove the entity from their minds.
However, the Foundation considers this method
to be impractical, time consuming, cost ineffective,
and is rendered utterly pointless if SCP-3002
has infected too much of a subject’s mind.
So instead, in order to prevent the spread
of SCP-3002’s influence, all Foundation
personnel are instructed to terminate any
person contaminated by this living thought.
This order is extended to that individual’s
family, friends, colleagues, and even acquaintances.
Given that SCP-3002 can take the form of any
information it chooses, written words, a sound,
even a telepathic signal, anyone even remotely
linked to someone the entity infects has to
be destroyed to stop any potential spread.
If you, or anyone you know, were to come into
contact with SCP-3002, the entity would be
able to take control of your entire consciousness.
All your memories would be ripe for the entity’s
picking.
SCP-3002 is able to sift through your temporal
lobe where memories are stored, and can not
only destroy and delete an infected person’s
memories, but can also create false memories
to replace them.
And all the while, you would be completely
unaware this was happening to you, stripped
of all your natural survival instincts while
SCP-3002 runs riot in your brain.
There is currently no known limit to how much
of someone’s mind SCP-3002 is able to mimic,
rewrite, alter, or remove.
When the entity alters one of your memories,
that memory will become an additional instance
of SCP-3002.
In other words, it can implant itself in every
moment of your life, making itself a part
of everything you remember about your own
personal past, and even the parts you can’t.
Once SCP-3002 has spread itself to every piece
of information stored inside your brain, the
next stage of infection begins and SCP-3002
is able to take full control of a person’s
body.
Much like before, this could be happening
to you without you even being consciously
aware of it.
Usually, this doesn’t come to much, and
infected victims will carry on their day to
day lives, acting no different to how they
would normally.
That is until SCP-3002 detects a new target
that hasn’t been infected yet.
When this happens, any people previously exposed
to SCP-3002 will collectively seek out the
uncontaminated individual, capturing them.
Once this happens, SCP-3002’s infected army
will force their new victim to join them.
The SCP Foundation considers SCP-3002 to be
extremely hostile, and a major threat to their
organization and the world at large.
Due to SCP-3002 being uncontainable, and able
to infinitely adapt, it has evaded capture
or termination for a considerable length of
time.
Having the ability to spread among human beings
via the information we share with each other
- speech, texts, emails, phone calls, any
information at all - means that potentially
any and all information could contain SCP-3002.
According to calculations of the Foundation’s
top researchers, 78% of humanity may be under
the influence of SCP-3002, without any awareness
that they have been infected.
While dangerous and unstoppable, SCP-3002
doesn’t operate purely on instinct.
It doesn’t infect as many minds as it can
just because it knows no other way.
Everything that SCP-3002 does is a premeditated,
calculated decision, with one nefarious intention,
one goal: to destroy the SCP Foundation from
the inside out by killing or infecting every
member of personnel.
Believe it or not, SCP-3002 didn’t begin
life as a sentient, infectious thought.
In fact, SCP-3002 was once a person, a regular
human being like you or I.
She even had a name: Lily Veselka.
It is widely believed that Lily Veselka became
what we now know as SCP-3002 due to the actions
of the Foundation itself.
Since becoming SCP-3002, Lily seems to have
been searching for any information she can
find regarding a highly secret operation conducted
by the SCP Foundation known as Project Lethe.
As well as this, she appears to have an interest
in a number of Foundation research facilities,
including Site E, and an off the books facility
located in Ukraine’s Uzhanskyi National
Park.
This is potentially where SCP-3002 was first
created.
If any of this is to be believed, then it
would certainly explain SCP-3002’s noticeable
aggression towards the Foundation, and its
attempts to infect its personnel as an act
of revenge.
After the project that turned Lily into a
living thought, SCP-3002 was later encountered
by the Foundation in its current form in South
Rock Penitentiary.
This prison, located near Lafayette, Indiana,
was visited by one Doctor Darryl Loyd, one
of the SCP Foundation’s researchers.
The prison’s psychiatrist, a woman named
Doctor Susan Fairbank, was the first to notice
the effects of SCP-3002 contamination on a
number of South Rock Penitentiary’s inmates.
During sessions with her, several of these
prisoners had mentioned an identical memory
to Doctor Fairbank.
The description of the memory from each of
the inmates followed the same structure.
The prisoner remembered taking a long walk
through a forest with their best friend at
the time.
This detail, the best friend, is most likely
SCP-3002 herself, imitating a figure from
each inmate’s own childhood memories.
At some point in this false, shared memory,
all the prisoners recalled having an argument
with their friend.
It was later learned that this figure was
Lily Veselka, approaching infected individuals
in their memories to ask them questions about
the project that had turned her into SCP-3002,
often demanding to know “What do you know
about me?” or “Has the project finished?”
The Foundation began to investigate this bizarre
instance of shared, anomalous memory, after
Doctor Susan Fairbank shared her findings
on an internet message board, describing what
she had witnessed to other psychology experts.
At first, Doctor Loyd, the Foundation’s
researcher sent to South Rock to gather more
information, labeled the situation as low-priority
research.
Given SCP-3002’s ability to adapt and take
the form of any information, it was able to
avoid immediate detection by the SCP Foundation,
and the full extent of Lily’s abilities
remained hidden.
Doctor Loyd originally classed SCP-3002 as
“Safe”, believing it was little more than
a shared childhood memory that the South Rock
inmates had described.
At first, those that had been infected with
this collective memory were able to recount
it with perfect accuracy.
But as Doctor Loyd continued to interview
and test the affected inmates, the details
became scarcer, and the memory became less
and less defined the further the SCP Foundation
looked into it.
Perhaps Lily recognized the Foundation’s
presence and remembered that they were the
ones responsible for turning her into a sentient,
memetic entity without physical form and started
hiding her tracks.
Maybe she was biding her time, hiding herself
away in the minds of the infected prisoners
until the time was right.
Little did Doctor Loyd realize at the time
just how far SCP-3002’s influence had already
spread.
Lily wasn’t just in the inmates’ heads,
but almost all of the prison staff too, who
were now spreading her further and further
without even realizing it.
Thinking that SCP-3002 would be easy to contain,
Doctor Loyd had the Foundation administer
amnestics to all of the infected inmates.
Amnestics are memory altering drugs that the
SCP Foundation uses to prevent any information
about SCPs being known to the public.
When dealing with memetic anomalies like SCP-3002
or SCP-2440, amnestics can be particularly
useful in removing a person’s memories about
a memetic SCP.
Doctor Loyd hoped that this would be the case
at South Rock, still thinking SCP-3002 was
nothing more than an anomalous shared memory
that could be removed.
However, removing the false memory that Lily
had implanted in the prisoners would not remove
her from all their other memories.
Additionally, one of the infected inmates
was not given amnestics and was brought back
to the Foundation for observation.
From there, SCP-3002’s influence has been
able to spread like a sickness through the
ranks of the Foundation’s own personnel,
without their knowledge or detection.
Every person whose mind SCP-3002 is able to
reach, becomes an unwitting carrier for the
infectious, living thought.
It is unknown exactly how many of the SCP
Foundation’s members are under the control
of SCP-3002, granting Lily access to the wealth
of secret information and plans that the Foundation
keeps hidden.
It doesn’t matter what level of clearance
someone would need to view it; if it’s information,
it’s another way for SCP-3002 to spread.
And information, as we know, can take any
form, be it a written file, a spoken conversation,
or even an informative YouTube video.
Now tell me again about that time we took
a walk together in the forest…
But before you do, go check out “SCP-1861
- The Crew of the HMS Wintersheimer” and
“SCP-4511 - SWINE GOD” for more nightmarish
SCPs!